But Japanese letters are always pronounced in the same way, which means that
pictures in English go from A to AH to A
to A, but Japanese AH
is always AH and the meaning of Japanese.  It's always
good, so well, if you want to
speak with clear pronunciation, you
should say the sound you write clearly.
Nedadashi I'm
not a student, I'm a student, but my teacher
is an amateur, so Japanese characters are always pronounced the same way,
but the pair ei is always
pronounced as .
OK OK but Mr.
Thomas I'm sorry please say the last word again I got it OK I
think Mr. Thomas probably spelled it wrong.
Yes, that's right.
This is
pronounced as a picture, so I accepted it.
Japanese characters are
basically always pronounced the same way
basically always, but the
pair ei is always
pronounced as always.  It's a
rule of pronunciation,
teacher, what's the rule?
However, there are cases where it is
pronounced as a picture, and
there are cases where it disappears completely.